Donc ça fait un moment, je ne sais même plus déjà, je pense que ça fait 3-4 ans que nous avons commencé le livre d'Ézéchiel.
Et Ézéchiel, c'était un sacrificateur, donc il faisait partie d'une partie du royaume de Juda qui avait été déporté.
Donc c'était Nébuchadnezzar, le roi de Babylone, avait attaqué Jérusalem et il avait pris une partie des personnes du royaume.
Et donc Ézéchiel faisait partie, tout comme Daniel, il faisait partie de ceux qui avaient été embarqués et emmenés à Babylone.
Et ils ont été emmenés à Babylone et c'était déjà un coup assez difficile parce que dans ce qu'ils connaissaient,
l'attachement qu'ils avaient même à la terre de Jérusalem, c'était difficile d'envisager le fait qu'ils puissent être déportés.
Mais pendant qu'Ézéchiel est déporté, donc à Babylone, il va avoir une vision de la gloire de Dieu.
Dieu va lui apparaître dans une vision glorieuse, c'est ce qu'on peut dire, vraiment une vision glorieuse,
sur les bords du Kébar, donc c'est un fleuve qui est relié à l'Euphrate.
Donc lorsque nous avions, sur la première partie au chapitre 1, on voyait cette mission où Dieu lui apparaît dans une vision glorieuse
et Dieu lui demande d'aller parler à la maison d'Israël qui était alors captive à Babylone.
Et quand Dieu l'envoie parler, la chose qu'il y a, c'est que eux qui étaient à Babylone espéraient,
c'est-à-dire qu'ils arrivent, malgré le fait qu'ils avaient été déportés à cause de leur péché,
ils avaient du mal à reconnaître que c'était à cause de leur péché qu'ils étaient à Babylone.
Donc ils espéraient secrètement pouvoir rentrer à Jérusalem,
ils espéraient que l'Égypte puisse vaincre Babylone et qu'ils soient libérés et qu'ils puissent rentrer.
Donc Dieu décide d'utiliser Ézéchiel,
et donc Dieu va lui dire ce qu'il doit leur dire, il va lui dire ce qu'il doit leur montrer,
ça c'était dans le chapitre 2, et il va symboliser ce qu'il doit leur montrer,
toujours dans cette vision, il va, dans la vision, il va donner un rouleau à Ézéchiel.
Donc le rouleau contenait des plaintes, des gémissements, des lamentations,
et Dieu lui ordonne de manger ce rouleau, c'est-à-dire qu'il était en train de lui dire
tu vas prendre ma parole, tu vas la digérer et tu vas la donner au peuple.
Et c'était des paroles très difficiles, c'était des paroles qui allaient totalement à l'inverse
de ce que le peuple qui était à Babylone pouvait entendre.
Et au chapitre 3, Dieu va lui donner des instructions,
donc Dieu va encourager Ézéchiel,
mais il va lui signaler comment le message va être accueilli.
Il l'encourage, mais il lui dit un moment,
ce que tu vas dire ne sera pas bien accueilli.
Ils vont rejeter ton message, quelques-uns écouteront,
mais la grande majorité aura du mal à accepter le fait
que le jugement tombera sur Jérusalem.
Et Dieu l'établit comme sentinelle.
Donc nous avions vu cette partie aussi où Dieu l'établit comme sentinelle,
comme une sentinelle.
Donc le principe d'une sentinelle, c'est d'être postée à des endroits clés
et de surveiller.
Donc aujourd'hui, ça se fait, on peut le dire que ça se fait toujours.
Vous allez trouver à certains endroits, il y a des postes de gendarmes à la frontière,
ce sont des sentinelles qui surveillent ce qui peut rentrer dans le pays.
Donc Dieu l'établit comme sentinelle pour voir et avertir.
Donc il était dans ce rôle où il devait voir le malheur qu'il était en train de venir
et il devait les avertir par rapport à ce jugement.
Mais Dieu lui demande de le faire selon sa façon.
Donc à un moment, au lieu de parler aux personnes,
Dieu va l'amener par plusieurs signes assez spéciaux.
Soit il va être muet, il y a des moments où Dieu va lui fermer la bouche,
il ne parle pas.
Soit il va lui demander, et c'est ce que nous avions vu dernièrement au chapitre 4,
au chapitre 4, on a vu que l'Éternel va utiliser Ézéchiel,
va parler au travers d'Ézéchiel avec divers signes
pour montrer les douloureuses circonstances que va traverser le peuple.
Donc à un moment, nous avons vu dernièrement au chapitre 4 que Dieu va ordonner à Ézéchiel
de ce... voilà, il va lui... c'est une vision qu'il lui donne encore
et il va devoir exécuter ce qu'il lui donne dans la vision.
Donc dans la vision, Ézéchiel devait prendre une brique,
il devait dessiner Jérusalem,
il devait dessiner Jérusalem qui était entourée par des tranchées, par des sièges.
Il devait prendre une poêle, mettre entre la brique,
mettre une poêle entre lui et la brique.
Et donc lui devait symboliser, il symbolisait les ennemis qui allaient venir assiéger Israël.
Et Israël était donc la pierre qui allait être attaquée.
Et donc il avait... Dieu lui ordonne, d'abord sur le côté gauche,
Dieu lui ordonne de rester pendant 390 jours.
Alors quand on dit, ce n'était pas de façon littérale,
mais ça veut dire qu'à certains moments de la journée,
pendant 390 jours, il devait rester allongé.
Il devait rester allongé sur le côté gauche.
Il ne devait pas bouger, il ne devait rien faire.
Vous pouvez essayer de rester pendant 6 heures.
6 heures même déjà quand on dormait, on ne peut pas rester du même côté tout le temps.
On va toujours être obligé de bouger.
Mais là, Dieu lui ordonne de le faire.
Et quand Dieu lui ordonne de rester pendant 390 jours,
chaque jour correspondait à une année.
Donc c'était en train de symboliser,
donc là ça symbolisait les années d'iniquité du royaume du Nord.
Donc pour rappel, à la mort de Salomon, du roi Salomon,
le royaume va être divisé en deux.
Donc il y a des tribus du Nord qui vont faire sécession,
il y a 10 tribus qui vont faire sécession,
il y a 2 tribus qui vont rester dans le royaume du Juda.
Mais le royaume du Nord va être plus tard détruit par la Syrie.
C'était la puissance qui a précédé Babylone.
Et donc, les 390 jours correspondaient à 3 siècles
pendant lesquels le royaume du Nord avait péché
et ne s'était pas tourné vers l'éternel.
Et finalement, Dieu les avait détruits par la Syrie.
Et ensuite, Dieu demande à Ézéchiel de se coucher sur le côté droit
pendant 40 jours pour symboliser les années d'iniquité du royaume du Juda.
Il n'y a pas d'explication claire.
Quand on regarde au niveau des commentaires bibliques,
il n'y a pas d'explication claire pour comprendre les 40 jours.
Mais les 40 jours ne veulent pas dire que la culpabilité de Juda était moindre.
Non.
Mais ce que nous pouvons constater à un moment,
c'est que nous voyons la miséricorde de Dieu
parce que pendant tout le temps où le royaume de Juda aussi a vécu,
nous allons voir un moment que malgré les péchés,
Dieu va susciter un moment des réveils.
Dieu va permettre que le peuple revienne à lui.
Mais après, le peuple péchait encore.
Donc, c'est dans ce sens aussi qu'on peut voir les 40.
Plusieurs commentateurs, chacun.
Il y a certains qui vont parler que ça peut être peut-être le règne du roi Salomon
qui va être caractérisé par la division du royaume à sa mort.
Donc, il y a plusieurs explications,
mais il n'y a pas une explication claire que la Bible nous donne
par rapport à ces 40 jours.
Mais, donc, pendant qu'il est en train de voir cette vision,
Dieu lui annonce aussi en vision une famine.
Il est en train de lui annoncer une famine
qui va faire rage à Jérusalem.
Et ce que nous devons remarquer, c'est que,
et c'est là où c'était difficile pour les captifs qui étaient à Babylone,
c'est qu'ils n'avaient jamais vécu des temps comme ceci.
C'est-à-dire que depuis toujours, malgré leur péché,
Dieu avait épargné Jérusalem.
Et donc, quand Dieu est en train d'annoncer par Ézéchiel
qu'il y a une famine qui va faire rage,
c'est Dieu l'a déjà annoncé par Ésaïe.
Ils ne l'ont pas écouté.
Pendant ce qu'Ézéchiel est en train de parler,
Dieu annonce la même chose à Jérémie.
Et donc, Dieu annonce une famine qui fera rage.
Et nous avions vu à la fin du chapitre 4,
c'est-à-dire un moment où Dieu va demander à...
Donc, pendant qu'Ézéchiel va être couché,
Dieu va lui demander de manger un pain spécial.
C'était un pain qui était composé de plusieurs céréales.
Et il devait faire cuire ce pain avec des excréments.
Donc, ce n'est pas qu'il mettait des excréments,
c'est que les excréments étaient utilisés comme combustibles.
Donc, c'était pour symboliser un moment
qu'ils allaient être dans une telle situation
qu'ils n'auraient même plus de quoi avoir,
de quoi chauffer leur nourriture.
Ils allaient être obligés de faire sécher des excréments
pour pouvoir réchauffer leur nourriture.
Et au moment où ils faisaient ça,
ça veut dire que leur nourriture était souillée
parce que Dieu l'interdisait.
Donc, Dieu utilise Ézéchiel
pour pouvoir exprimer le jugement à venir.
Et aujourd'hui, dans ce chapitre 5 que nous avons lu,
nous allons plutôt être dans l'introduction,
l'introduction de ce passage.
Et dans l'introduction,
nous voyons que le chapitre 5, dans son ensemble,
c'est un chapitre qui est en train de rentrer
dans les détails du jugement.
C'est-à-dire, il est en train d'expliquer les jugements
mais il est en train d'expliquer aussi
pourquoi toutes ces choses sont en train d'arriver à Israël.
Et donc, quand nous lisons là sur l'ensemble du chapitre,
nous allons voir par exemple,
aujourd'hui nous verrons la première partie.
Donc, la première partie, c'est du verset 1 au verset 4.
C'est un aspect où Dieu va demander à Ézéchiel de se raser.
Donc, il va devoir se raser la barbe,
il va devoir se raser tous ses cheveux
et il va devoir les brûler.
Il va devoir brûler une partie
et une autre partie de ses cheveux,
il va les disperser au vent.
Et là encore, c'était un signe.
Donc, toutes ces choses,
Ézéchiel les reçoit dans des visions
mais plus tard, Ézéchiel va les exécuter.
Donc, Dieu lui dit à un moment
qu'il devra prendre,
par exemple, je prends un exemple,
brûler un tiers dans le feu au milieu de la ville.
Donc, ça veut dire à un moment
que plus tard, ce qu'Ézéchiel fera,
quand il aura coupé ses cheveux,
il va prendre une partie
et lorsque toutes les personnes sont en train de le regarder,
il brûlera ses cheveux au milieu de la ville.
Et même si les personnes lui posent une question,
ce sera pour leur faire comprendre
ce qui va arriver à Jérusalem.
Donc, c'était quelque chose d'assez difficile.
Et dans la deuxième partie
du chapitre 5,
que nous ne verrons pas aujourd'hui,
nous verrons maintenant
que lorsqu'il fait ce signe du rasage,
on va voir maintenant
que ce signe est maintenant appliqué à Jérusalem
et avec le rappel
que c'est le péché
et la cause de cette désolation.
Le fait d'avoir méprisé la loi de Dieu,
d'avoir méprisé le sanctuaire de Dieu,
va découler ce jugement.
Donc, dans cette première partie aujourd'hui,
nous allons voir cet aspect
dans les versets du verset 1 au verset 4.
Donc, là encore,
là Dieu l'avait déjà...
Nous avons vu au chapitre 4
que Dieu l'oblige à être couché
pendant un certain nombre de jours
et à fixer une brique,
ou même à se tourner face à la brique.
Mais là, maintenant,
Dieu l'utilise comme signe
au travers de ses cheveux,
de sa barbe,
et les gens pourront voir
qu'il est concerné.
C'est-à-dire que ce que Dieu est en train de faire,
un des aspects dont nous avions parlé aussi,
c'est que...
Excusez-moi.
C'est que...
Ézéchiel,
dans ce qu'il représente,
est aussi une figure du Christ à venir.
Il est en train d'annoncer le Christ.
Et lorsqu'il est en train de...
Aujourd'hui...
Lorsqu'il est en train de vivre toutes ces choses,
le fait de se raser,
le fait de faire ces choses,
il est en train de montrer
que lui-même il est concerné.
Il n'est pas juste en train de dire
le jugement arrivera,
repentez-vous,
mais il est en train de montrer
que lui-même il est concerné.
C'est un fardeau qu'il porte.
Et qu'il doit même faire plus attention
au message qu'il donne
parce que ça veut dire
que ce n'est pas quelque chose
qu'il fait pour le plaisir de le faire.
Et donc,
il montre qu'il est affecté
par le sort de Jérusalem
et qu'il montre ce qu'il y a dans son cœur
malgré la désolation
qu'il est en train d'annoncer.
Et donc là, au verset 1,
la parole lui dit
« Et toi, fils de l'homme,
prends un instrument tranchant,
un rasoir de barbier,
prends-le et passe-le
sur ta tête et sur ta barbe.
Prends ensuite une balance apaisée
et partage les cheveux. »
Pour la didactique de cette prédication,
je devais me raser hier,
mais je ne me suis plus rasé.
Je me suis dit qu'on comprendrait mieux
le parallèle avec Ézéchiel.
Par le geste que Dieu est en train de lui demander,
Dieu est en train de confirmer
le rejet et l'abandon du peuple.
Il est en train de montrer
que maintenant,
cette génération,
il n'y aura plus de retour en arrière.
Dieu va aller jusqu'au bout
de ce qu'il a annoncé.
Et donc,
Dieu demande à Ézéchiel
d'utiliser un instrument tranchant.
Donc là,
il va prendre un rasoir
pour se raser la barbe
et pour symboliser
ce que Dieu va faire.
Et donc,
de façon allégorique,
ce que Dieu est en train de montrer,
c'est que Jérusalem
est comme la tête.
Jérusalem est une tête
qui est devenue souillée
à cause du péché
de son peuple
et ses cheveux représentent
la population de Jérusalem.
Et quand je parle de Jérusalem,
je parle en fait même du royaume
dans l'ensemble.
Je parle du royaume
de Judas.
Donc,
Dieu est en train de montrer
un moment que maintenant,
ils étaient devenus,
vous savez,
à un moment,
vous avez les cheveux qui poussent.
À un moment,
ça commence à péser,
à gratter.
Et puis,
c'est là,
on va chez le coiffeur
parce qu'à un moment,
on n'arrive plus à supporter.
Et donc là,
c'est ce que Dieu voulait symboliser
parce qu'il est arrivé
à un niveau où
même Jérusalem
ne pouvait plus supporter
le poids du péché du peuple.
Et donc,
Dieu était en train
de juger.
Donc,
voilà ce qu'il était en train de dire
lorsqu'il est en train
de se raser la tête.
Donc,
il ne doit pas seulement
couper la partie qui déborde.
Dieu ne lui demande pas juste
de couper les cheveux
qui débordent.
Dieu lui demande
de couper
tous les cheveux.
Et ce que Dieu symbolisait,
c'est que du moment
où il fait comprendre
que s'il avait juste coupé
la partie qui déborde,
ça voulait parler aussi
que Dieu permettait encore
des temps
de repentance.
Dieu permettait encore
des temps où son jugement
pouvait être arrêté.
Mais le fait que
Ézéchiel soit en train
de tout enlever,
est en train de symboliser
le fait que Dieu
va aller jusqu'au bout
de ce qu'il est en train
d'annoncer.
Et quand nous sommes
en train de réaliser ça,
il est important de voir
à un moment que ce qu'il est
en train d'annoncer
à Ézéchiel,
il l'a annoncé
à d'autres prophètes
avant Ézéchiel.
Même des années,
des années avant,
c'est-à-dire avant même
qu'Ézéchiel puisse être né
à cause des péchés
qu'ils avaient commis.
C'est-à-dire que lorsque
Israël se retrouve
à rentrer dans la terre
de Canaan,
Dieu les rassemble
et il les sépare
en deux groupes.
Donc, il y a un groupe
où on va prononcer
toutes les paroles
de bénédiction
qui sont attachées
à l'Éternel
si Israël est attaché
à l'Éternel.
Et il y a un groupe
où ils prononceront
toutes les paroles
de malédiction
si Israël s'éloigne.
Et à partir du moment
où Dieu établit ça,
du moment où Israël
va pécher,
malgré le fait
que Dieu va les amener
à se repentir
et qu'ils vont continuer
à aller contre ces paroles,
la parole de l'Éternel,
les paroles de malédiction
qui avaient été prononcées
vont finir par se réaliser.
Donc, quand ces choses arrivent,
plusieurs prophètes
avaient déjà annoncé
ce qu'Ézéchiel
est en train d'annoncer.
Et donc, Dieu dit
qu'il va raser Jérusalem,
il va enlever
tous les habitants
de Jérusalem,
il va totalement détruire
le royaume.
Et là,
la suite du verset,
il dit à un moment
« Prends ensuite
une balance à peser
et partage les cheveux. »
Cette partie du verset
nous rappelle
que les jugements de Dieu
s'exercent toujours
avec équité.
Donc, ce qu'il est en train
de dire,
il va exercer son jugement,
mais il est en train
de préciser à un moment
que ce n'est pas
quelque chose
qui se fait
sous un coup de tête,
sous une mauvaise inspiration.
Vous savez,
souvent quand nous lisons
l'histoire des dieux grecs,
on va voir un moment
que Zeus,
ça lui prend de faire
quelque chose,
il n'y a aucune raison,
mais il décide
de faire du mal.
Non, nous,
nous avons un Dieu
qui est juste
dans ce qu'il est
en train de faire.
Et ce qu'il est en train
de rappeler à un moment,
lorsqu'il prend ce passage
de prendre une balance
à peser
et de partager les cheveux
qui seront divisés
en trois parties,
il est en train
de rappeler
que ce jugement
s'exerce toujours
avec équité.
Et lorsque
ce jugement s'exerce,
ce jugement
peut nous sembler dur
et c'est normal
parce qu'à un moment,
nous,
par rapport à la compréhension,
d'ailleurs,
Paul va dire,
je donne la référence
1 Corinthien 1131,
il va dire à un moment
que si nous nous jugions
nous-mêmes,
nous ne serions pas jugés.
Si nous appliquons
nos propres critères
de jugement,
de vérité,
de droiture
à nos propres vies,
nous allons justifier
beaucoup de choses.
On dira par exemple
à un moment
qu'on a menti
lorsqu'on nous a appelés
alors qu'on était
dans la maison,
on a dit
qu'on n'était pas là
mais on a menti
parce qu'on était fatigué
donc on ne pouvait pas
dire la vérité.
Donc,
on va toujours trouver
des excuses
pour justifier
notre mauvaise conduite.
Et si nous devions être jugés,
aucun de nous
ne serait jugé,
on allait toujours trouver
des motifs.
Mais ce que la parole
nous montre à un moment
c'est que Dieu
n'était pas en train
de juger Israël
sur des critères humains.
Il était en train
de juger sur ces critères
de vérité
et de droiture.
Et nous devons
comprendre à un moment
que même si aujourd'hui
nous avons totalement
baissé ces critères
ou nous avons même
du mal
dans nos générations
à accepter
le jugement de Dieu,
nous avons dans cette génération
du mal
à accepter
l'idée de l'enfer,
nous devons savoir
à un moment
que Dieu ne baissera pas
ces critères
à cause du péché
que nous portons.
Les critères de Dieu
seront toujours
des critères basés
sur sa vérité,
sur sa droiture.
Et donc il est en train
de dire un moment,
il va parler
des cheveux
qui vont être dispersés
de prix en trois parties
et il est en train
de symboliser par là
que sa justice,
sa justice divine
va s'exercer,
il va punir les uns
par une sorte de jugement,
il punira les autres
par d'autres sortes
de jugements,
c'est ce que nous allons voir.
au verset 2.
Et la symbolique
des cheveux
était très importante
parce que dans Israël
et même dans plusieurs nations
environnantes,
le fait de se raser
les cheveux
était une symbolique
très importante.
Donc généralement,
on allait se raser
les cheveux
si on était touché
par un deuil,
on allait se raser
les cheveux
si on avait perdu
sa liberté
ou son honneur.
Donc voilà pourquoi
par exemple,
des femmes comme des hommes,
lorsqu'ils étaient
faits prisonniers,
quand on attrapait
les prisonniers,
ce qu'on faisait d'abord,
c'était de leur raser
les cheveux
parce que ça symbolisait
leur honneur perdu.
Voilà,
et c'était une honte
infligée.
Et d'ailleurs,
il y a un exemple,
là je vous donne
juste pour rappel,
mais il y a un passage,
ce passage dans la Bible
où le roi David
va prendre le décès
d'un roi,
le roi Damone,
qu'il est respecté beaucoup.
et donc il va envoyer
ses ambassadeurs
pour marquer sa solidarité
dans le deuil.
Mais par contre,
le fils de ce roi
qui a repris le pouvoir
va mal agir,
il va humilier
les messagers de David.
Et donc,
il va leur raser la barbe
et il va même
les renvoyer
à moitié nus.
Et ce que la parole
de Dieu nous dit
à un moment,
c'est que David
va leur recommander
de rester à Jéricho
jusqu'à ce que
leur barbe
ait repoussé.
Donc,
on voit l'importance
quand Dieu est en train
de parler,
c'est-à-dire que
quand le peuple
va voir
Ézéchiel
qui est en train
de totalement
se raser
alors qu'il n'était pas
censé toucher à sa barbe,
totalement en train
de se couper les cheveux,
lorsqu'on sait
ce que ça représente,
ça sera un signe.
C'est-à-dire que
même s'ils ne parlent pas,
quand ils verront,
ils vont s'interroger
par rapport à ce qu'il
est en train de faire.
Je vais dire,
dans un sens,
ça change beaucoup
de nos prophètes
qui sont dans des costumes
trois pièces
et qui prédisent
les vainqueurs
de compétition de foot.
Mais,
nous voyons
que les prophètes
que Dieu désignait
étaient là
pour pointer
le péché du peuple,
étaient là
pour montrer,
pour redresser le peuple,
pour leur montrer
qu'est-ce qu'était
la vérité
liée à la parole.
Et donc,
verset 2,
il dit à un moment,
brûle,
brûle-en un tiers.
Donc,
il prend ses cheveux,
il rase les cheveux
de la tête,
la barbe,
il les met
ensuite
une balance
à peser
et il partage
les cheveux
en trois parties.
Ensuite,
il doit en brûler
un tiers dans le feu.
Donc,
brûle-en un tiers
dans le feu
au milieu de la ville
lorsque les jours
du siège
seront accomplis.
Prends-en un tiers
et frappe-le
avec le rasoir
tout autour de la ville,
disperse-en un tiers
au vent
et je tirerai
l'épée
derrière eux.
Un tiers
des cheveux
coupés
devaient être brûlés
au milieu de la ville
pour désigner
les nombreuses personnes
qui allaient périr
à cause de la famine,
à cause de la peste
et beaucoup
qui allaient même périr
dans l'incendie de la ville
parce que quand nous lisons
la fin de ce siège,
d'ailleurs,
nous avons des indications
de la fin de ce siège
dans Jérémie
et ce qui est encore plus troublant,
c'est de voir que
tout ce que Dieu
est en train de décrire
dans la répartition
des cheveux,
c'est exactement
ce qui s'est passé
lorsque nous lisons
le livre de Jérémie.
Et donc,
la ville va être incendiée
et beaucoup de personnes
vont même mourir
dans l'incendie de la ville
lorsque les jours du siège
vont être accomplis
et que les babyloniens
vont finir par prendre Jérusalem.
Donc,
ce premier tiers
devait être brûlé
au milieu de la ville.
Un second tiers
devait être coupé
en morceaux
avec le couteau
à un rasoir
et ça représentait
toutes les personnes
pendant le siège
qui allaient être tuées
par l'épée.
C'est-à-dire,
pendant le siège,
certains allaient être tués
lorsqu'ils allaient sortir
pour se battre
contre les babyloniens,
d'autres allaient être tués
lorsque la ville
allait être prise d'assaut.
Et ce qu'il y a,
c'est que lorsque
les babyloniens
vont prendre la ville d'assaut,
ils vont la prendre
avec beaucoup
de férocité,
de cruauté.
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'à un moment,
pendant tout le temps
du siège,
ils vont ordonner
à Jérusalem
de se rendre.
Ils vont ordonner
aux autorités
de se rendre.
et les...
les...
Judas,
le royaume de Judas,
ils vont refuser
de se rendre
parce qu'ils espéraient
un secours de l'Égypte.
Donc, ils pensaient
que l'Égypte allait venir
intervenir
parce que là,
c'était aussi
notre puissance de l'époque.
Ils espéraient
que l'Égypte intervienne.
Donc, l'Égypte oblige...
Et d'ailleurs,
ça s'est même passé un moment
lorsqu'il y a eu le siège,
Dieu a permis,
comme ça.
Donc, à un moment,
l'Égypte va intervenir
et Nebuchadnezzar
va devoir lever
le siège de Babylone
pour aller combattre
les Égyptiens.
Mais dès qu'il va vaincre
l'Égypte,
il va revenir.
Mais dans leur orgueil,
ils auront du mal
à accepter le fait
de se rendre.
Et voilà pourquoi
lorsque les Babyloniens
vont prendre la ville,
ils vont être
d'une cruauté
assez grande
où ils vont
vraiment massacrer.
Il y a vraiment
un faible reste
qui va rester.
Donc ça,
c'est cette seconde partie.
Et la troisième partie,
c'est une partie
qui devait être dispersée
par le vent.
Et c'est la partie
qui symbolise
à un moment
ce qui va se passer.
C'est-à-dire qu'il y a
quelques-uns
qui vont quand même
réussir à fuir.
Il y a quelques-uns
qui vont être emmenés
à Babylone
pour rejoindre
Ézéchiel et les autres
ou même dans d'autres nations
parce qu'ils étaient dispersés.
Il y a d'autres
qui vont fuir
dans les pays voisins
pour trouver un refuge.
Et Dieu est donc
en train de symboliser cela
par les cheveux
qui sont détachés au vent.
Mais,
il donne une indication.
Il dit à un moment,
malgré le fait
que ses cheveux
vont être dispersés au vent,
il va tirer l'épée
derrière eux.
Il rajoute
qu'il tirera l'épée
derrière eux
de peur qu'ils ne pensent
que cette dispersion
serait leur évasion.
Il va tirer l'épée
derrière eux
afin que partout
où ils aillent,
ils réalisent le jugement.
Le problème,
souvent,
quand les jugements
de Dieu s'exercent,
de Dieu apparaissent
du moment où
nous sommes en train
de les vivre,
il est souvent très difficile
de ne pas voir
la main de Dieu.
À un moment,
nous allons réaliser
un moment que là,
il y a quelque chose
qui nous interpelle,
qui montre même
que ce que nous sommes
en train de vivre
n'est pas naturel.
Et quand les jugements
de Dieu s'exercent,
donc il est difficile
de ne pas voir
la main de Dieu
parce que les jugements
de Dieu sont exercés
pour mettre à nu
notre culpabilité.
Quand Dieu exerce
ses jugements,
c'est pour montrer,
c'est pour étaler,
c'est pour exposer
le péché.
Et alors,
nous devons faire preuve
d'humilité
et nous devons reconnaître
que ces jugements
nous arrivent
à cause de nos péchés.
Et c'était drôle,
par exemple,
lorsque Dieu permet
dans sa souveraineté,
il va permettre le COVID.
Nous voyons comment
c'était une situation
qu'aucun d'entre nous
n'avait jamais vécue.
Et d'ailleurs,
personne d'entre nous
ne pouvait dire
de quoi l'avenir
allait être fait.
C'était extraordinaire
de voir que là,
aussi bien,
quel que soit,
que tu sois docteur,
scientifique,
politicien,
analyste de comptoir,
parce qu'on en a eu beaucoup,
personne ne pouvait dire
de quoi demain serait fait.
Et là,
Dieu est en train
de remettre en cause
beaucoup de choses
dans nos vies.
Dieu est en train
de remettre en cause
des choses liées au péché.
Mais ce qui va se passer,
c'est que l'interpellation
que nous allons voir,
et d'ailleurs,
nous avons eu
une grande bénédiction
parce qu'au travers du COVID,
beaucoup de personnes
ont commencé
à chercher Dieu,
à étudier leur Bible,
par rapport au temps
que Dieu donnait.
Ils ont étudié la Bible,
ils ont même pu revenir
dans ce que Dieu recommandait.
Mais nous voyons
qu'au fur et à mesure
que nous étions en train,
les jours du COVID
étaient en train de passer,
on voyait que l'orgueil
de l'homme
était en train
de reprendre le dessus.
On était en train
de voir à un moment
que l'orgueil de l'homme
les poussait à remettre
en cause la main de Dieu
parce que le jugement
était en train
d'être atténué.
Et comme on espérait
maintenant des vaccins,
des choses comme ça,
on commençait à se dire
à un moment,
il y a même certains
qui avaient dit,
faites attention,
les chrétiens vous diront
à un moment
que ça vient de Dieu
alors qu'il n'y a rien
que c'est la main du hasard.
Mais ce que nous voyons,
les jugements de Dieu,
aujourd'hui,
il y a un jugement constant.
Un des jugements constants
que nous subissons
dans ce monde,
c'est l'effet du péché.
L'effet du péché dans le monde
et les conséquences du péché
sont suffisants
pour nous expliquer
pourquoi toutes ces souffrances
et pourquoi notre besoin de Dieu.
Malgré le fait
que nous sommes toujours
en train de vouloir chercher
des solutions humaines
par la technologie,
par la psychologie,
par beaucoup de voies,
nous voulons essayer
de voir une main du hasard
dans ces choses.
Mais à un moment,
nous voyons à un moment
que nos cœurs
sont dans un besoin
que nous n'arrivons pas
à combler.
Et nous voyons à un moment
que nous sommes
liés à une puissance,
à la puissance du péché
dont nous n'arrivons pas
à sortir.
Et pour ça,
il suffit juste
malgré toutes les bonnes volontés
que nous avons,
nous sommes au 21e siècle,
malgré tous les progrès scientifiques,
il suffit juste
de voir le journal
ou de voir des émissions télévisées
où on ne va faire
que parler de meurtre,
on ne va faire que parler
d'escroquerie,
de beaucoup de choses mauvaises.
Et nous constatons
à un moment
que malgré tout le vernis
que nous voulons donner
dans ce monde,
c'est un monde qui est malade.
Et donc,
il y a un péché,
il y a un jugement
que Dieu a exercé
dès le péché d'Adam et Ève.
Mais il y a aussi
des jugements temporaires
que Dieu exerce sur les nations.
À un moment,
chacune des nations,
lorsqu'elles se détournent
du Seigneur,
de ce que Dieu a établi,
même comme ses lois naturelles
et qu'elles sont bafouées,
Dieu exerce ses jugements
sur les nations.
Et un exemple,
pour bien réfléchir aussi à ça,
je vais prendre l'exemple,
on ne va pas tout lire,
mais dans 1 Samuel,
dans 1 Samuel,
nous avons un exemple
très pertinent.
Donc,
c'est l'exemple d'Élie,
donc de 1 Samuel,
1 Samuel,
au début de 1 Samuel,
ça nous raconte
les débuts
du prophète Samuel,
qui va même être
le juge en Israël.
Et ça nous raconte aussi
comment,
à partir du chapitre 4,
verset 6,
ça nous raconte
les jugements
que Dieu va exercer.
Alors,
Samuel a été confié à Élie,
qui était le souverain
sacrificateur.
Donc,
c'est 1 Samuel 4,
donc 4 à 6.
Il a été confié à Élie,
qui était le sacrificateur,
mais à un moment,
Élie a péché,
parce qu'Élie a vu
ses enfants péchés,
ses enfants qui étaient
sacrificateurs,
il ne les a jamais repris.
Il a permis
que le péché soit même
au milieu du sanctuaire
de l'Éternel.
Donc,
ce que Dieu va faire,
c'est qu'il va décider
de punir Élie et ses enfants.
Et donc,
ce qui se passe,
c'est qu'il va avoir
une bataille,
il va avoir une bataille
où Israël
va aller se battre
contre les Philistins
et ils vont perdre
la première partie
de la bataille.
Et quand ils perdent
la première partie
de la bataille,
ils vont dire
c'est parce que l'arche
de l'alliance de l'Éternel
n'était pas là.
Donc,
ils vont envoyer
chercher l'arche
de l'alliance de l'Éternel
et ils vont revenir
avec l'arche
et donc les fils d'Élie
et ils vont espérer
que maintenant
qu'il y a l'arche
de l'alliance de l'Éternel,
Dieu va leur donner
la victoire.
Mais ce qui se passe,
c'est que Dieu va permettre,
Dieu va au contraire
les humilier.
Donc,
les fils d'Élie
vont être tués,
Israël va perdre
la bataille
et l'arche
de l'alliance
va être enlevée.
Donc,
c'était quelque chose
de totalement,
c'était une humiliation
totale
de perdre
ce qui symbolisait
la présence de Dieu
au milieu du peuple
et que ce soit
chez les Philistins.
et lorsque ces choses
arrivent,
donc les Philistins
se disent à un moment
c'est notre Dieu
qui nous a donné la victoire,
nos dieux.
Donc,
ils vont emmener
l'arche de l'alliance
dans leur ville
et quand ils apportent
l'arche de l'alliance,
ils vont remarquer
à un moment
que là où est l'arche,
ils vont commencer
à avoir des jugements
de Dieu,
des crises d'hémorroïdes,
beaucoup de personnes
vont mourir
et ce qu'ils font,
c'est qu'ils transportent
l'arche dans une autre ville.
Ils transportent l'arche
dans une autre ville,
là encore,
les mêmes jugements
de Dieu
sont en train de s'accomplir.
Ils l'ont fait au moins
quatre ou cinq fois
et là,
il n'y avait plus
de doute possible.
C'était la main de Dieu.
C'est-à-dire,
dans ce qui est en train
de se passer,
ils savaient à un moment
que le Dieu,
le Dieu d'Israël
à qui appartenait cette arche
était en train
de les juger
parce qu'ils avaient cette arche.
Donc,
ils vont décider,
ils ont des sages
qui vont leur dire
à un moment,
nous vous recommandons
de prendre cette arche
et de la renvoyer
en Israël.
Et quand ils,
je vais juste pour,
c'est toujours bien
qu'on lise,
mais je voulais vraiment
prendre ce point
parce que souvent,
cette idée
d'imaginer un hasard
lorsqu'il y a
l'exercice
des jugements
de Dieu
est très important
que nous puissions
écarter cela
et que nous comprenions
à un moment
que Dieu,
dans sa justice,
permet aussi
ces jugements.
et donc,
lorsqu'ils vont,
donc,
ils vont consulter
leurs sages,
donc,
ces sages vont leur proposer
un moment,
ces sages vont leur proposer,
c'est,
au chapitre 6,
donc,
les sages vont leur demander,
ils vont leur dire
si,
chapitre 2,
1 Samuel,
chapitre 6,
verset 3,
donc,
les sages leur dire,
si vous renvoyez
l'arche du Dieu d'Israël,
ne la renvoyez point à vide,
mais faites à Dieu
un sacrifice de culpabilité.
Donc,
ils reconnaissent un moment
que c'est la main de Dieu
qui s'est exercée
sur toute leur ville,
alors vous guérirez
et vous saurez
pourquoi sa main
ne s'est pas retirée
de dessus vous.
Donc,
là,
ils sont avertis là-dessus,
mais nous voyons
au verset 9,
c'est-à-dire que
comme les jugements de Dieu
sont en train de s'atténuer,
verset 9,
voilà ce qu'ils disent maintenant,
ils vont prendre l'arche,
ils vont mettre des...
ils vont mettre des vaches
qui allaitent,
donc ils vont mettre des vaches,
ils vont créer un char,
ils vont mettre l'arche
et ce sont des vaches
qui allaitent
et ils vont dire
à un moment
que ces vaches
doivent prendre
une certaine direction
et si ces vaches
prennent une certaine direction
et elles vont jusqu'à
un certain point précis,
ça veut dire
que c'est Dieu
qui a permis cela.
Donc vous voyez
que même là,
il y a déjà la conviction
qu'il y avait Dieu
mais ils reviennent
encore en arrière
et se disent non,
finalement non,
c'était peut-être pas Dieu,
il ne faudrait pas
qu'on se laisse berner.
Donc il dit à un moment,
verset 9,
« Suivez-la du regard,
si elle monte par le chemin
de sa frontière
vers Berchemesh,
c'est l'Éternel
qui nous a fait ce grand mal.
Sinon nous saurons
que ce n'est pas sa main
qui nous a frappés
mais que cela nous est arrivé
par hasard. »
Et donc ils ont fait ainsi.
Ils ont fait ainsi
et ils ont pris des vaches
qui allaitaient
parce qu'il est très difficile
pour une vache,
donc ils sont allés mettre
les enfants du côté opposé,
les petits,
et c'est très difficile
pour une vache
qui allait de partir
dans une direction opposée
et de laisser ses petits.
Donc ils se disaient
« Si ça vient de Dieu,
si ça ne vient pas de Dieu,
les vaches vont repartir
vers leurs petits. »
Sauf que les vaches
ont pris un chemin.
Ils ont suivi les vaches
jusqu'au bout
et les vaches sont allées
jusqu'à là où elles devaient aller.
Et quelque part,
Dieu était en train
de leur donner une leçon
pour leur montrer
à un moment que non,
ce n'était pas le hasard.
Et nous devons comprendre
à un moment que Dieu,
quand Dieu exerce
ses jugements
et que nous voyons
clairement aussi
la main de Dieu,
nous devons prier
pour que nous prenions conscience
et que nous puissions
nous repentir.
Alors,
pour nous chrétiens,
c'est beaucoup plus évident
lorsque Dieu nous punit
à cause d'un péché
dans notre vie,
de reconnaître sa main,
de nous repentir.
Mais c'est vrai aussi
que pour les nations
dans lesquelles nous sommes,
ce sera difficile
de l'accepter.
Mais nous devons prier
pour que la repentance
soit la réaction
à ce que Dieu
est en train de faire.
et donc,
dans le cadre
du jugement
avec Ézéchiel,
donc,
ce que Dieu
était en train de faire,
lorsqu'il est en train
de parler,
il dit même que
même là,
je tirerai l'épée,
c'est-à-dire que
même pour ceux
qui ont enfui
dans des nations,
donc,
il y en a qui vont fuir
en Égypte
en se disant
nous serons en sécurité
en Égypte,
rien ne peut nous arriver
mais l'épée
va les poursuivre
jusqu'en Égypte
parce que ce qui va se passer,
c'est que
Nébuchadnezzar,
après avoir pris Jérusalem,
son prochain objectif
ce sera d'attaquer l'Égypte.
Il va finir par envahir
toute l'Égypte.
Donc,
même cette guerre,
même là où il se disait
qu'il s'avait échappé
au jugement de Dieu,
le jugement de Dieu
allait finir par les rattraper.
Voilà le sens
que Dieu
était en train de mettre
lorsqu'il était en train
de parler
de son épée
qu'il allait tirer
derrière eux.
Au verset 3,
il dit un moment,
tu prendras
une petite quantité.
Donc là,
il doit faire ça,
mais lorsqu'il a dispersé
les trois groupes
de cheveux,
il y a des cheveux
qui doivent brûler,
il y a d'autres
qui doivent découper
devant les gens,
il y a d'autres
qui doivent disperser
au vent.
Mais Dieu lui demande
dans la partie
dispersée au vent,
Dieu lui demande
de prendre une petite quantité
qu'il va serrer
dans les bords
de son vêtement.
Et ça,
c'est en train
de signifier
la petite poignée
de personnes
qui allaient rester
par suite
à Jérusalem.
Et c'est cette petite poignée
qu'ils espéraient
pouvoir garder le pays.
Et d'ailleurs,
nous le voyons,
c'est pour ça que je dis
à un moment,
c'est extraordinaire
de voir comment
toutes ces choses
se sont accomplies
par la suite.
Dans Jérémie 39,
je donne la référence,
mais je vais le lire
parce que j'ai là.
Jérémie 39 nous dit
à partir du verset 8,
les Chaldéens brûlèrent
par le feu
la maison du roi
et les maisons du peuple
et ils démolirent
les murailles de Jérusalem.
Nébuzaradan,
chef des gardes,
emmena captifs
à Babylone
ceux du peuple
qui étaient demeurés
dans la ville,
ceux qui s'étaient rendus
à lui
et le reste du peuple.
Mais Nébuzaradan,
chef des gardes,
laissa dans le pays
de Juda
quelques-uns
des plus pauvres du peuple,
ceux qui n'avaient rien
et leur donna alors
des vignes
et des champs.
Et voilà ce que Dieu
est en train de symboliser.
Donc,
Dieu va établir
Gedalia
qui va être avec
quelques compagnons
pour surveiller
et là où
on peut se dire
à un moment,
c'est encore un fruit du hasard,
ce que les Babyloniens
faisaient souvent
dans de pareils jugements,
c'était de détruire
entièrement la nation.
Comme ça,
ils n'allaient même pas
laisser des restes
et ce qu'ils faisaient,
c'est qu'ils détruisaient
entièrement
et ils exportaient,
c'est-à-dire qu'ils allaient
chercher une nation
qu'ils avaient vaincue ailleurs
et qu'ils allaient installer
à la place de cette nation.
Mais là,
ce que Dieu va faire,
c'est que Babylone,
sans savoir
qu'est-ce que c'était
dans les dessins de Dieu,
Nébuchadnezzar
va ordonner
qu'une partie du peuple,
donc parmi les plus pauvres,
qu'il y ait un reste
qui reste à Jérusalem.
Et là,
c'est ce que Dieu
avait annoncé à Ézéchiel,
qu'il y aurait un reste
qui devrait rester
en disant un moment,
il y aura quelques-uns,
tu prendras une petite quantité
que tu serreras
dans les bords
de ton vêtement.
Et il dit encore,
donc parmi ce reste,
et de ceux-là,
donc de ceux-là
que tu auras serré
dans le bord
de ton vêtement,
tu en prendras encore
quelques-uns
que tu jetteras au feu
et que tu brûleras
dans le feu.
De là,
sortira un feu
contre toute la maison
d'Israël.
Normalement,
c'est un reste
qui devait être épargné,
mais là,
Dieu indique à Ézéchiel
qui a encore
quelques éléments
de ses cheveux
qu'il a mis à part
qu'il devra
jeter au feu.
Et lorsque nous lisons
encore cette partie,
donc je vais vous laisser,
je vous laisserai lire,
je donne la référence,
vous pourrez lire,
mais c'est donc,
c'est cette partie
à partir de Jérémie 39,
ça va jusqu'à Jérémie 42
à peu près,
ça nous explique
cette partie-là.
Donc,
Gedalia,
qui allait être
le gouverneur
établi par les Babyloniens,
va être tuée
par manque de sagesse.
On va lui tendre un piège
et on va le tuer.
Et il y a quelques personnes
qui vont,
les personnes qui l'ont assassiné
vont décider de fuir en Égypte
parce qu'elles ne voulaient pas
rester sous la domination
des Babyloniens.
Et donc,
ils ont tué Gedalia.
et ils vont proposer à Jérémie,
ils vont proposer à Jérémie
de partir avec eux.
Et quand ils proposent à Jérémie,
c'est intéressant
parce qu'ils disent à Jérémie,
nous allons te laisser,
vu que l'Éternel te parle,
nous allons consulter l'Éternel
pour nous
et ce qu'il te dira,
nous le ferons.
Et Jérémie les met en garde
en disant qu'il sait
qu'ils ne vont pas écouter
l'Éternel,
mais Jérémie va quand même
écouter Dieu
et Dieu va utiliser Jérémie
pour leur dire un moment
de ne pas aller en Égypte.
Il va utiliser Jérémie
pour leur dire
de rester là où ils sont
et de se soumettre à Babylone.
Mais là,
ils vont dire à Jérémie
que c'est un menteur,
ils vont lui dire un moment
que c'est un ami de Jérémie
qui l'a entraîné à mentir.
Et donc, finalement,
c'est ce reste dispersé là
qui va fuir.
Donc,
ce petit reste,
la Bible nous dit un moment
au verset
de là sortir un feu
contre toute la maison d'Israël.
Ce qui va se passer,
c'est qu'à cause d'eux,
d'autres jugements
vont intervenir sur les nations
et vont fuir.
S'ils étaient restés à Babylone,
le Seigneur aurait même
épargné des nations environnantes.
Mais comme ils vont décider
de ne pas se soumettre,
parce que Dieu avait décidé
qu'ils se soumettent
aux Babyloniens,
mais ils vont dire
qu'à un moment,
ils ne se soumettent pas aux Babyloniens,
ils vont fuir.
Et ce qui va se passer,
c'est que Dieu va les poursuivre
dans les nations.
Donc, voilà pourquoi
on nous parle d'une calamité.
Dieu nous parle d'un moment,
un feu qui sortira encore
contre toute la maison d'Israël.
Parce que là,
Dieu va les poursuivre
et Dieu va même apporter la guerre
dans les nations
où ils s'étaient réfugiés.
Et ils ne connaîtront pas la paix
parce que le jugement de Dieu
avait été établi contre eux.
Et la leçon que nous tirons
lorsque, pour Ézéchiel,
c'était très difficile,
c'était très difficile
d'envisager ce fait
de ce jugement sur Jérusalem
parce qu'ils étaient conscients
à un moment que Dieu
avait choisi Israël.
Ils étaient conscients
à un moment que Dieu
était l'ornement de Dieu.
Mais par contre,
ce que Dieu est en train
d'enseigner à un moment,
et donc Dieu va juger
les nations par la suite.
Babylone sera jugée,
la Syrie va être jugée.
Mais nous devons prendre conscience
et c'est pour nous aussi
ce que Dieu nous enseigne
au travers de cela,
c'est que nous pouvons souvent
penser à un moment
que le jugement de Dieu
n'atteindra pas sa maison.
Mais ce n'est pas
ce que les Écritures
nous enseignent.
Les Écritures nous enseignent
à un moment que le jugement
de Dieu commencera par sa maison.
Le trouble,
là je fais un parallèle,
mais c'était assez troublant
de voir un moment que
lorsque le Covid commence,
et qu'est-ce que le Covid
nous enseigne aussi,
c'est de comprendre,
de nous arrêter,
de nous souvenir
que Dieu,
qui est Dieu,
de celui qui règne,
les premières attaques
vont être contre des Églises.
Des Églises vont être attaquées.
Et d'ailleurs,
pour des Églises,
il y aura une remise en cause,
même pour beaucoup d'Églises,
par rapport à certaines choses
qu'ils portaient,
et un jugement
qui va être exercé.
C'était drôle
parce qu'il y a des Églises
qui, malgré ce que le gouvernement,
malgré le confinement
qui avait été mis en place,
certains faisaient tout
pour maintenir leur culte
parce qu'ils avaient besoin
des offrandes.
Vous imaginez un moment
qu'on pourrait comprendre
qu'on va maintenir un culte
parce que,
j'ai parlé des chrétiens persécutés.
Aujourd'hui,
c'est le jour du Seigneur.
Il y a des frères,
malgré ce que les autorités
dans les pays
où ils sont,
leur ont ordonné
de ne pas faire,
ils sont en train de le faire.
Ils se sont rassemblés,
ils sont en train de s'exhorter
sur la parole de Dieu
et ils sont en train
de s'encourager
malgré les moments difficiles
qu'ils traversent.
Mais nous avons vu
un moment
que pour certains,
le fait
de ce qu'ils étaient
en train de vivre,
ça voulait dire
qu'ils étaient en train
de perdre un gain financier.
Ça voulait dire
qu'ils étaient en train
de perdre un système
qu'ils avaient mis en place,
beaucoup de bonnes choses
qu'ils avaient mises en place
qu'ils trouvaient bonnes pour eux.
Mais nous comprenons
à un moment
que le jugement de Dieu
était aussi en train
de passer sur les églises.
Dieu était en train
de juger
et si ceux qui sont destinés
à être des monuments
de la grâce de Dieu
ne l'ont pas été
mais vont plutôt choisir
de se plonger
dans les péchés des nations
dans lesquelles Dieu les appelle
à refléter sa gloire,
le jugement
tombera aussi
sur l'église.
Et le rappel pour nous,
c'est important
de comprendre
à un moment
que Dieu
n'est pas préoccupé
par le nombre
que nous sommes.
Dieu n'est pas préoccupé
par les programmes
que nous pouvons avoir
dans une église.
Dieu n'est pas préoccupé
par
l'excellence académique
de ses membres
parce qu'il y a des églises
qui sont faites
pour des hommes riches
comme ça on exclut
ceux qui peuvent gêner
mais nous serons jugés
par rapport
à la fidélité
à la parole de Dieu.
Le seul critère
que Dieu honore
c'est le fait
qu'une église
soit fidèle
à sa parole.
J'ai pris l'exemple
de Elie tout à l'heure.
Vous voyez,
c'est quelque chose
de difficile
d'envisager un moment
que Dieu décide
de...
Donc,
quand les enfants
d'Elie vont mourir
j'ai pris l'exemple
de 1 Samuel
Elie va mourir
par la suite
c'est-à-dire que
la nouvelle
lorsqu'il va apprendre
que l'arche de l'alliance
est tombée
entre les mains
des Philistins
la nouvelle
va être tellement choquante
qu'il va tomber
à la renverse
qu'il va se briser
la nuit
qu'il va mourir.
Mais Dieu a choisi
Dieu a choisi
que son nom
soit bafoué
il a préféré
que son nom
soit bafoué
plutôt que d'être associé
à des gens
qui étaient en train
de pécher.
Du moment
où ils étaient
dans le péché
et ils ont dit
à un moment
nous pouvons pécher
mais s'il y a
l'arche de l'alliance
nous savons
à un moment
que Dieu sera
avec nous.
Ça n'a pas marché
parce que Dieu
ne s'associe pas
au péché.
Dieu ne bénit pas
là où il y a
le péché.
donc Dieu a préféré
que l'arche
de l'alliance
tombe
entre les mains
des Philistins
il a préféré
que l'arche
de l'alliance
tombe entre
les mains
des Philistins
que sa gloire
soit bafouée
mais il s'est chargé
lui-même
de restaurer sa gloire
et nous devons
avoir confiance
en Dieu.
Nous n'avons pas
un moment besoin
même de défendre
la gloire de Dieu
ce à quoi Dieu
nous appelle
c'est d'être fidèle
dans sa parole
dans l'église
c'est d'être fidèle
à annoncer sa parole
Dieu est juste
dans ses jugements
et ce qu'il a fait
un moment
c'est qu'il a jugé
les Philistins
sans aucune
intervention humaine
il a permis
que l'arche
de l'alliance
revienne
en Israël
sans aucune
intervention humaine.
Esaïe 5
du verset 16
au verset 21
nous dit
l'éternel désarmé
sera élevé
par le jugement
et le Dieu saint
sera sanctifié
par la justice
des brebis pèteront
comme sur leur pâturage
et des étrangers
dévoreront
les possessions
ruinées des riches
malheur à ceux
qui tirent l'iniquité
avec les cordes du vice
et le péché
comme avec les traits
d'un char
et qui disent
qu'il hâte
qu'il accélère son œuvre
afin que nous le voyons
que le décret
du Saint d'Israël
arrive et s'exécute
afin que nous le connaissions
malheur à ceux
qui appellent
le mal bien
et le bien mal
qui changent
les ténèbres
en lumière
et la lumière
en ténèbres
qui changent
l'amertume
en douceur
et la douceur
en amertume
malheur à ceux
qui sont sages
à leurs yeux
et qui se croient
intelligents
nous devons
pour nous chrétiens
n'ayons pas peur
d'être fidèles
à la parole
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
aujourd'hui
ça devient difficile
et on ne sait même pas
jusqu'à quand
on sera même autorisé
à dire à un moment
que Dieu
a permis aujourd'hui
que l'enfer existe
parce que même
au milieu des chrétiens
il y a aujourd'hui
dans certains milieux
chrétiens
on a du mal
à accepter l'idée
de l'enfer
parce qu'elle est incompatible
avec le Dieu
d'amour
mais ils oublient
qu'elle est compatible
avec un Dieu saint
et juste
dans ses jugements
elle est compatible
avec un Dieu vrai
avec un Dieu saint
et la Bible nous dit
à un moment
l'éternel des armées
sera élevé
par le jugement
Dieu exerce
ses jugements
pour que les nations
se souviennent
qu'il est celui
qui règne
Dieu exerce
ses jugements
et il dit à un moment
qu'il est sanctifié
lorsque sa justice
est exercée
et voilà pourquoi
à un moment
il va permettre
que des jugements
temporaires
arrivent
parce que ces jugements
temporaires sont là
pour nous rappeler
que Dieu
est celui
qui règne
au-dessus de toute chose
et il y a des moments
dans le cœur de l'homme
on a dit
malheur à ceux
qui tirent l'iniquité
avec les cordes du vice
à un moment
l'homme va être
dans le péché
et qu'ils disent
qu'il hâte
qu'il accélère son œuvre
afin que nous la voyions
donc là
c'était des personnes
qui se moquaient
des haïs
ils étaient en train
de dire
c'est bien beau
tu es en train
de dire des paroles
de nous dire
que Dieu va juger
mais nous
on aimerait voir ça
il faut qu'il se dépêche
il faut qu'il accélère
parce que nous
on ne voit rien
jusqu'à présent
et Dieu dit à un moment
malheur à ceux
qui sont en train
de résonner ainsi
malheur à ceux
qui sont sages
à leurs yeux
et qui se croient
intelligents
malheur à ceux
qui définissent
le bien
selon leurs critères
et non les critères
de Dieu
malheur à ceux
qui définissent
le mal
selon leurs critères
et non les critères
de Dieu
et malheur encore
un malheur encore
plus grand
si nous nous disons
croyants
et que nous nous permettons
de décrire
ce que nous jugeons
bon
ou mal
non pas selon
les critères bibliques
mais selon
nos convictions
personnelles
mais nous
nous devons être
conscients
que les jugements
temporaires
que Dieu exerce
même lorsqu'il annonce
ce qu'il a annoncé
à Ézéchiel
ce sont des choses
qui se sont
complètement accomplies
il les avait annoncés
à Ésaïe
à Ézéchiel
il les a
complètement accomplies
mais je vous ai
parlé aussi
du péché
qui est dans ce monde
mais ça nous rappelle
un moment
qu'il y aura
un jugement final
les jugements
temporaires de Dieu
nous mettent en garde
nous appellent à être
dans la repentance
appelle le monde
à être de la repentance
nous chrétiens
à être engagés
dans la sainteté
parce qu'il y aura
un jour
de jugement final
qui sera inévitable
et qui sera même
encore plus destructeur
mais c'est un jour
où quand nous lisons
dans la parole
le Seigneur nous dit
à un moment
que ses élus
seront en train
de le louer
pour sa justice
ses élus
seront en train
de le louer
parce qu'il est saint
et qu'il est juste
dans l'exercice
de ses châtiments
nous croyons
nous avons la grâce
de savoir
que nous n'ignorons pas
comment ce monde
est apparu
la parole de Dieu
est claire
c'est Dieu
qui a créé
cette terre
c'est Dieu
qui a créé
tout ce qu'elle contient
le péché
est arrivé
à cause
de l'orgueil
de Satan
qui a aussi
trompé les hommes
dans l'orgueil
dans le péché
mais nous connaissons
la finalité
de ce monde
voilà pourquoi
nous ne plaçons pas
notre espérance
dans ce monde
voilà pourquoi
notre espérance
ne va pas être basée
sur l'espérance
des biens terrestres
que nous avons
mais sur l'espérance
de Dieu
nous n'ignorons pas
les conséquences
du péché
et de ce qu'il porte
dans nos vies
dans le monde
même si aujourd'hui
l'homme essaye
de tout
par tous les moyens
possibles
d'enlever cette idée
d'un Dieu
et c'est l'idée
aujourd'hui les gens
accepteraient beaucoup
l'idée d'un Dieu
et ils acceptent même
sur d'autres religions
du moment où c'est un Dieu
qui peut accepter
nos efforts
ou que c'est un Dieu
qui ne nous juge pas
le problème
que la plupart des gens
ont avec Dieu
c'est le fait
que c'est un Dieu
qui va mettre à nous
notre culpabilité
c'est que c'est un Dieu
qui va exposer nos péchés
mais nous voyons
les conséquences
du péché dans le monde
et nous savons
à un moment aussi
ce que Dieu
porte
et ce que Dieu
a fait au travers
de l'œuvre de Christ
nous ne devons pas
non plus ignorer
lorsque nous sommes
en train de lire
ces paroles
c'est très important
pour nous
donc si tu n'as jamais lu
l'Ancien Testament
ça peut arriver
j'ai rencontré
des chrétiens
après plusieurs années
dans la foi
qui n'avaient jamais
ouvert l'Ancien Testament
qui lisent en boucle
le Nouveau Testament
parce que là
ils trouvent un Dieu
plus chaleureux
et ce sont des gens
qui n'ont pas compris Dieu
parce que Dieu
est le même
dans l'Ancien
comme dans le Nouveau Testament
il est chaleureux
dans l'Ancien
dans le Nouveau
il est juste
dans l'Ancien
dans le Nouveau
il est saint
dans l'Ancien
dans le Nouveau
donc nous ne devons pas
ignorer
parce qu'à un moment
nous avons l'impression
nous nous disons
un moment
mais il y a des questions
comme ça
que certains chrétiens
vont dire un moment
mais pourquoi tant
de souffrance
pourquoi Dieu
n'exerce pas
ses jugements
pourquoi Dieu
permet de telles situations
mais il suffit juste
de lire la Bible
pour comprendre
que Dieu
donne toujours
des temps de repentance
mais il y a toujours
un moment
où ses jugements
s'exercent
et donc
nous ne devons pas
ignorer les paroles
qui ont été annoncées
par les prophètes
tout au long
de l'Ancien Testament
et nous constatons
à un moment
que ces paroles
se sont accomplies
sur Israël
là encore
Dieu nous a enseigné
quelque chose
il dit à un moment
voyez
l'ornement
mon ornement
que j'avais
ici bas
à cause du péché
à cause du fait
à un moment
qu'ils ont péché
toutes les malédictions
qui avaient été prononcées
se sont accomplies
sur eux
et donc
Dieu est en train
de nous dire
à un moment
si il a jugé
Israël
qui était
sa nation
combien
comment il ne jugera pas
les autres nations
qui ne lui appartiennent pas
et qui sont même encore plus
dans le péché volontairement
si Israël
qui connaissait
la loi de Dieu
a été jugé
combien les nations
qui ignorent Dieu
si nous qui sommes croyants
nous sommes jugés
lorsque nous péchons
et que nous
subissons les conséquences
de notre péché
mais par la grâce de Dieu
Dieu ne nous punit
jamais à la hauteur
de ce que nous méritons
sinon aucun d'entre nous
ne serait dans cette salle
si nous
Dieu exerce
ses jugements sur nous
lorsque nous péchons
comment il épargnera
celui
qui frontalement
décide de pécher volontairement
et décide
d'ignorer sa justice
je vais finir
1 Pierre 13
finir avec la lecture
de 1 Pierre
1 Pierre 1
parce qu'il n'y a pas
1 Pierre 13
j'attendais des réactions
mais
donc 1 Pierre chapitre 1
du verset 13
au verset 21
donc comme je disais
si nous sommes conscients
et nous devons toujours
nous souvenir
nous voyons comment
ce que Dieu annonce
à Ézéchiel
il l'a accompli
parfaitement
comme nous le voyons
dans Jérémie
nous ne pouvons pas
ignorer
que notre Dieu
est fidèle
aussi bien
dans les bénédictions
qu'il donne
que dans les malédictions
lorsque sa loi
lorsque sa parole
n'est pas honorée
et les temps
que nous avons
actuellement aujourd'hui
sont des temps
de rafraîchissement
où Dieu permet
que l'Église
soit continue
à intercéder
pour le salut
où Dieu permet
que nous puissions encore
pour ceux qui ne le connaissent pas
se tourner vers lui
et voilà ce que
Pierre va dire
suite à toute la conscience
de ces choses
parce que c'est l'exemple
qu'il va prendre
au début
il va parler un moment
je crois même
je vais commencer
au verset 8
il dit
lui que vous aimez
sans l'avoir vu
il parle du Christ
en qui vous croyez
sans le voir encore
vous réjouissant
d'une joie ineffable
et glorieuse
parce que vous obtiendrez
le salut de vos âmes
pour prix de votre foi
les prophètes
donc Ézéchiel
Ésaïe
Jérémie
et tous les autres
les prophètes
qui ont prophétisé
touchant la grâce
qui vous était réservée
ont fait de ce salut
l'objet de leurs recherches
et de leurs investigations
voulons sonder l'époque
et les circonstances
marquées par l'esprit de Christ
qui était en eux
et qui attestait d'avance
les souffrances de Christ
et la gloire
dont elles seraient suivies
il leur fut révélé
qu'ils étaient les dispensateurs
de ces choses
que vous
que vous ont annoncé
voilà
qu'ils étaient les dispensateurs
de ces choses
que vous ont annoncé
maintenant
ceux qui vous ont prêché
l'évangile
par le Saint-Esprit
envoyé du ciel
et dans lesquels
les anges désirent
plonger leur regard
nous avons une grâce
immense
parce que ce que Christ a fait
les prophètes ont annoncé
Christ
ils ont même donné
une image de Christ
au travers de leur souffrance
et il y a eu Christ
qui est venu
accomplir quelque chose
de plus grand
que ces prophètes
qui nous donnaient des signes
et Christ
nous a donné le salut
et Pierre va dire
c'est pourquoi
saignez les reins
de votre entendement
soyez sobres
et ayez une entière espérance
dans la grâce
qui vous sera apportée
lorsque Jésus Christ
apparaîtra
dimanche dernier
je ne sais pas si c'était
ou deux dimanches
mais en tout cas
je crois que dimanche dernier
quand notre frère Loïc
nous parlait
du principe de l'espérance
selon la parole de Dieu
ce n'est pas une espérance
qui est liée au hasard
parce qu'à un moment
on va espérer
à un moment
qu'il y ait peut-être
un Uber disponible
il se peut qu'il n'y ait pas
de Uber disponible
mais l'espérance
selon la parole de Dieu
c'est quelque chose
qui est certain
où nous pouvons placer
notre confiance
nous sommes sûrs
que ça arrivera
et donc Pierre le dit
à un moment
ayez une entière espérance
dans la grâce
qui vous sera apportée
lorsque Jésus Christ
apparaîtra
comme des enfants
obéissants
ne vous conformez pas
au convoitice
que vous aviez autrefois
quand vous étiez
dans l'ignorance
demorons dans la vérité
ne soyons pas
cette église
ces personnes
qui s'éloignent
de la parole
et qui redéfinissent
ce qui est bien
selon leurs critères
ce qui est mal
quand Dieu
va nous confronter
ça peut être difficile
d'accepter
les critères de Dieu
en termes de bien
et de mal
mais c'est quelque chose
de bon pour nos âmes
mais puisque celui
qui vous a appelé
est saint
puisque celui
qui vous a appelé
est saint
vous aussi
soyez saint
dans toute votre conduite
selon qu'il est écrit
vous serez saint
car je suis saint
et si vous invoquez
comme père
celui qui juge
selon l'oeuvre
de chacun
sans exception
de personne
conduisez-vous
avec crainte
pendant le temps
de votre pèlerinage
sachant que ce n'est pas
par des choses
périssables
par de l'argent
ou de l'or
que vous avez été
racheté de la vaine
manière de vivre
que vous aviez
hérité de vos pères
mais par le sang
précieux de Christ
comme d'un agneau
sans défaut
et sans tâche
prédestiné
avant la fondation
du monde
et manifesté
à la fin des temps
à cause de vous
je vais finir
au verset 21
à cause de vous
qui par lui
croyant en Dieu
lequel a ressuscité
des morts
et lui a donné
la gloire
en sorte que
votre foi
et votre espérance
reposent sur Dieu
Amen